we first brought you this tragic story
on friday tonight police have identified
the 26 year old mother of two
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us now with the latest details
right here in the sierra vista
neighborhood is where metro police
arrived on friday to find two children
dead
their mother amanda sharp jefferson is
now in custody 26 year old amanda sharp
jefferson is facing murder charges
after metro police found evidence that
the mother of two harmed her children
intentionally
on friday metro police received a call
from the children's father
that his children were injured and lying
in their living room unresponsive
once police arrived the children were
pronounced dead on scene
the oldest child we do not know
what exactly the cause of death is going
to be
on the younger child we have a very good
idea what the cause of injury is however
i'm not going to get into that right now
until after autopsy
a neighbor who lives across the street
says she is praying for the father
and that sharp jefferson needs
psychiatric evaluation
i saw the kids and i have to stand on my
porch and look right into the window
where it happened
in the kids room there over there and
it just makes me sad you know i just
hope everything be
all right for them you know and the lady
goes to some kind of
treatment you know because i know she's
going to need it
sharp jefferson will appear in court on
tuesday november 10
at 7 30 a.m she is facing two counts of
open murder
live in las vegas madison kimbrough 8
news now